[Music]  consider two dilemmas you are a  university student and you discover that  your roommate who is also your best  friend has cheated on an exam you wonder  whether to report her to university  authorities or suppose you were an  excellent swimmer and you're a member of  your country's Olympic swimming team  shortly before the swimming event you  discover that a teammate has been taking  illegal performance-enhancing drugs you  wonder whether to report him to the  authorities thinking about these  dilemmas raises a question about loyalty  and truth-telling do you think it is  sometimes right  to lie or to hide the truth to protect a  friend a teammate or a compatriot who  has done something wrong  you